Instructor: If sets
are to arrays, then maps are to
objects. A map works very
similar to a set, however it has
a key and a value instead of
just values. Right here,
I've gone ahead and created a
new map, which is dogs, and I've
set Snickers to 3, Sunny to 2,
and Hugo to 10. We'll talk about
the actual values that this can
take. Spoiler -- both the keys
and the values can be absolutely
anything. There is a very
simple API for actually working
with it. We called .set() here
when you want to set something
on it. Let's bring it over to
here. dogs.has(Snickers), that
will be true. You use .has() and
you use the key of it. You can
use dog.get() to actually get
the item. Whereas with sets, we
weren't able to reference it at
all. You can use dogs.delete(
Hugo) to see who's in there. Now,
dogs is just a map of Snickers
and Sunny. One interesting
thing about maps is that you can
loop over them in two ways.
First of all, we can use dot for
each, and that will give us a
value and a key. You can console.
log() the val and the key, and
that will give us the value of
the key, value of key, value of
key. We can also use our
trusty for-of loop that we've
been using all over this series.
For const dog of dogs, open that
sucker up, console.log(dog).
What's interesting about that is
it actually gives us an array,
where the first item is the key
and the second item is the value.
You might be thinking, "I know
what to use for that. We can use
the actual destructuring here.{
Instead of saying key dogs, we
can say key in val, and then we
have a key and a val, separate
variables here, that log out
separately for us. You can use
dogs.clear() to get rid of them,
or you can individually delete
one with .delete(). That's
interesting about a map, but why
is that better than actually
using an object? It seems like
it has a little bit of a limited
API. The one benefit here is
that you can use your for-of
loop with a map, but that is
also coming to objects sometime
in the future of JavaScript.
In the next video, what I want
to do is show you how you can
actually use a map for what's
called metadata.